you have to help me find out what  happened at my husband  seeking answers is never  a straight line  [Music]  police are closing the case his widow  deserves answers you saw the same thing  i did you still want to face it  [Music]  blackout gonna do the podcast force the  police to look deeper into the case  i won't only find out what you want me  to know eritol  this season we will present the  information ignored by the media  and the police we know what our friends  want us to know about their marriages  it's like a client you mean  [Music]  i'm worried about papi her marriage  she's coming loose at the seams do you  trust her  if  how does that make you feel like burning  it down  you thought that you could control me i  don't know  what you're talking about you have to be  honest with me  why did you even want me involved with  this case  [Music]  my name is poppy parnell and i will not  give  up until i have  the truth  know your life